you clicked on it let's do this
hi guys and welcome to tipsy Thursday
here on it's grade I went on my tumblr
and they asked you guys what did you
want to learn how to do today and you
gave me so many great suggestions but I
didn't take them and I decided to do my
own idea anyway but I read them and I
appreciated them and I'm glad you spend
time using your fingers to type
excellent use of time except not at all
you could have done something way better
with that time today I'm gonna teach you
how to dye your hair i impress myself by
the time you're watching this video I
will be headed to playlist live the
YouTube convention in Orlando Florida
and I decided that because my hair has a
slight green tint to it after dyeing it
twice I'm gonna dye it thrice and in
doing so I'm gonna teach you how to dye
your hair as if you couldn't read the
[ __ ] directions for yourself but hey
that's what the Internet's for
our steps dyeing your hair is to put on
clothes that you don't give a [ __ ] about
getting [ __ ] up
done second step to dyeing your hair
just letting yourself absorb the fact
that you are voluntarily doing this to
yourself you went out and you purchased
the color and no one's holding a gun to
your head or a feather to your feet you
are responsible step 3
let's evaluate the hair color we've
purchased but not for too long as the
Spiker sells out from what we're about
to do i purchased l'oreal paris Feria
and it's called French Roast look at
that girl so if you don't know I
recently just dyed my hair brown from
blonde though I am a natural brunette
and the first two times I bought the
hair color it was the same color and I
bought it because the female on the box
had brown eyes and brown hair and so I
likened myself to her and thought if we
look I think similar this should be okay
and then the ends of my hair turned up a
little green I decided that I'm gonna go
with a woman with green eyes and
hopefully the ends of my hair will turn
out Brown because the at philosophy
makes perfect sense
let me be your cult leader next step is
to analyze the emotional state that the
model in the front of your haircolor box
is in she seems a little sleepy but sexy
flexy next step up in the box o
treasures soon you and I are gonna have
the same hair color next step is to read
the instructions they're probably good
for you Oh
always read protection oh yeah be sure
your hair is dry done on shampooed super
done and detangled well
I'll be a girl rules twist-off
shimmering conditioning developer cream
bottle put more adjectives please
boo-boo-boo-boo-boo-boo-boop science for
ladies oh this is some breaking bed
ladies right now
welcome to you to learn drink then
basically what we do is we put it all
over yeah let's do it
so I'm gonna start at the bottom cuz the
bottom is what needs to color there's
gotta be a better system to this I just
do like umm what was that game that you
had when you were younger spin art
mister like a spin art oh my eyes are
watering that's how you know it's
working once you start to look like
someone accidentally pushed you in a
pool when you weren't suspecting it you
know it's going well I can hear the
collective cringe of every hair person
out there being like why and stop and
also why and please stop what I do is
after my eyes have stopped burning a
little bit then they get a brush and I
brush my hair out to make sure that the
mixture is evenly distributed the
ripping noise means that's okay
hair grows back what I do is I take a
hair tie and I put my hair on the top of
my head because this color has to sit
for 25 minutes let's do it did it Holly
at 25 minutes has passed ish
I forgot exactly what time I started
this so this seems like enough now if
I'm dead rinse it out of your hair then
you can have the shower and you realize
that nothing has really changed
picks up for your dirty dirty t-shirt
and
the smell of your hair even that guy
stays constant nothing to dry your hair
and see what actually happened okay it's
dry and it's not as green as it was
before it looks really red in this
lighting but it doesn't in real life I
think I don't know I haven't styled it
wait I don't know if I feel sexy issue
feels but I definitely feel sleepy but
this I don't know the cool thing on down
your hair Brown is that you start to
look like you work in a coal mine
and then people respect you because you
work very physically hard for very
little pay